الهان عمر تحت مقصره الاكثريه الجمهوريه
في مجلس النواب اتم استبعاد النائبات
المسلمه من لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه رغم
معارضه الديمقراطيين للقرار السبب تصريحات
سابقه لها بشان اسرائيل وصفت بالمعاديه
للساميه الهام عمر التي خدمت في هذه
اللجنه لسنوات اعتبرت ان القرار ينطوي على
اسباب تتعلق بارثها كمهاجره لاجئه من دوله
مسلمه
هناك فكره مفادها انك مشتبه به اذا كنت
مهاجرا او قادما من اجزاء معينه من العالم
او اسود او مسلما ليس من قبيل الصدفه ان
اعضاء في الحزب الجمهوري اتهموا اول رئيس
اسود في البلاد الرئيس اوباما بانه مسلم
وقد عبر للبيت الابيض عن دعمه لالهام عمر
مشيرا الى انها اعتذرت عن تلك التصريحات
بينما وصف زعيم الاقليه الديمقراطيه في
مجلس النواب ما جرى بالانتقام السياسي
ما يحدث اليوم في مجلس النواب ضد الهان
عمر ليس نقاشا بشان السياسه العامه او
المساءله بل يتعلق بالانتقام السياسي رغم
نفي رئيس المجلس الجمهوري لهذه الاتهامات
بين مراقبين يعتبرون قرار اقصاء الهان عمر
واخرين كاظم شيف من لجنه المخابرات ارضاء
للجناح اليميني الذي ساهم في انتخاب
ماكارتي وايضا للسماله لوبيات واصوات
الناخبين اليهود
عليه ان يقدم شيئا لاعضاء حزبه لن يكون
قادرا على تقديم ذلك من خلال السياسه بل
عن طريق ما يرضي غضبهم اقصاء النواب من
عضويه اللجان اجراء استثنائي في العاده
لكنه اضحى في السنوات القليله الماضيه
سلاحا يستخدمه كلا الحزبين
الديمقراطيون اتخذوا خطوات مماثله عام
2021 بحق نواب الجمهوريين ابرزهم النائبه
اليمينيه مارجري تايلر جرين ردا على نشرها
محتوى على الانترنت وصف بانه تحريض على
العنف في وقت كانت البلاد لا تزال تتعافى
من احداث السادس من يناير رغم مواقف الهان
عمر التي توصف بالمثيره للجدل فانها انضمت
الى اكثر من 30 نائبا ديمقراطيا في
التوقيع على مشروع قانون جديد يدعم
اسرائيل كحليف للولايات المتحده ويدين
معادله الساميه لكنها اكدت في الوقت نفسه
ان انتقاداتها للسياسه الامريكيه
والاسرائيليه تجاه الفلسطينيين لم تتغير
محمد الاحمد الجزيره واشنطن